[music]
Okay. Hello everyone. Welcome to Makina.
Uh it looks like I'm interviewing four
robots. Um but who I have here are the
founders of these companies. Um uh as
well. And uh um see we have a couple
more people coming in. Um I'm Justina
Chong. and I'm with Bessmer Venture
Partners based in London where we invest
from seed companies all the way to
growth um across the layers from robotic
models to infrastructure and the robot
makers. And on the panel today we will
discuss the realities of deploying and
running robots at scale and who better
to do that with than four veteran
operators in the space. And so to start
things off, I'll ask each of you to do a
brief introduction, but also to set the
stage and the context for the audience
here. You know, what form factor do you
work with? What's the use case? Um, and
where are you at in deployment?
>> All right, I'll start. Thanks so much.
My name is Peter, co-founder and CEO of
Eddie Botex. It's on the picture on the
very left. What we build is inspection
solutions based on robots for the
process industry. And the reason is in
the process industry, it's all about
asset integrity, running the facilities
safely, but we don't have enough people.
We cannot put sensors everywhere. So
what we're doing is sending in robots
with four legs because they can maneuver
through these complex environments,
carry a lot of sensors on top, visual
thermography, acoustic gas detection,
you name it. They run full autonomous
and then they run daily, you know, hours
and hours collecting thousands of
inspection points. And based on that,
we're building the AI to understand
what's going wrong, notify the operators
and tell them what's happening such that
they can take action earlier on.
>> Hi everyone, I'm Tristan uh co-founder
and chief product at Nomagic. Uh you
know at Nomagic we're actually not
having robot that move. They're static
but they're focusing on manipulation. So
we're doing item handling in warehouses.
Those are generally industrial robots
that we install. It's like solutions
that are one or two robotic arms. They
can use multiple tools and do all kinds
of item handling and item manipulation
first in fulfillment warehouses and
basically expanding progressively to
other types of warehouses.
>> Hi, I'm Tomas. I'm one of the
co-founders and the CEO of Sunrise. Uh
we do intelligent robotic cells for
highmix low volume manufacturing. Um
deployed mainly in electronic
manufacturing services now but um we'll
do a lot of other stuff. And our product
looks a little bit like this. So much
more like a machine than uh than a
traditional robot system with tons of
cameras, lots of edge compute, and two
arms uh to poke the world around us. And
we get them to work by uh visiting a
customer facility, taking lots of video,
and showing up a couple of weeks later
uh with this machine just ready to get
to work. So happy to talk about how that
that looks like in reality.
>> Hello together. Nice to meet you all.
I'm F from Sheffller. Um we call
ourselves the motion technology company.
Um so we mainly serve in automotive and
industrial sector and due to the fact
that we have over 100 plants in the
world automation is really important for
us to drive our operational excellence.
In Sheffller I work in the innovation
field. So we in the end translate um
early technologies to our production
plants and so we drive mainly their um
yeah automation with different form
factors from conventional industrial
robotics up to humanoids which you see
on the picture. So this is one use case
we applied in a plant in Germany where
we brought really physical AI to our
production world.
>> Great. Thank you everyone. Um, so we're
going to talk a lot about the friction
involved and ways to reduce time to
value um, in what you do day-to-day. But
to start and kick things off, you know,
maybe let's start with war stories. Um,
you give the room a sense. Um, and I
love that we have panelists across
different form factors and and fields
here. Um, what was the hardest the most
challenging deployment you've worked on
and what helped to solve that?
>> Or I can start if you want. [laughter]
So, so our our the most difficult is
generally at the beginning, right?
Because you know when you're early in
your journey, you make a lot of mistakes
and in hindsight they look like all
rookie mistakes. So, so the the second
customer we had, which is Brack, it's
the second largest e-commerce platform
in Switzerland. Um, we installed our
first couple of robots there. And, you
know, in hindsight, I'm thinking
everything was wrong there, right? Like,
so, so the layout was sub-optimal. were
supposed to do a preparation of orders
where we're picking from one bean and
placing into another bean. There are
small details like the distance between
the beans that they've set up was 1.5
meter. And and we told them, well, how
about we put the beans next one to
another? You know, it's going to be just
making the process much faster. And they
told us, yeah, but we don't care too
much about speed. Well, never trust
that, right? We don't care too much
about speed. No, you don't care too much
about speed until this thing is
productive. And then at that point,
you'll care only about speed, right? And
and so you're basically learning the
things that you know as it's the usual
product management thing, right? Like
you need to listen to the customer, but
you shouldn't listen, you know, with
with um without a little bit of a grain
of thinking of what is the long term for
them, right? So there we had to change
the layout. We had to change the robot
brand. We started with a robot that was
like operating well but not to the
reliability level you want when you're
running 247. Um we had to change the
tools. We're operating with one tool and
over time you know we need to take
millions of items. So it's really the
iteration that matters I think is the
message right
maybe on our side I mean by now we have
hundreds of deployments and everyone is
always different. Imagine you're sending
in robots into complex environments
there's grass growing on there's snow
falling there's always something right.
Um, one of the deployments for sure was
was challenging because we're working in
aluminum production and the floor is so
oily. You've never seen that even people
hold on to the handrails and that's
decades of oil built up and still
producing just coming over the machines.
There's no way to clean it. It'll get
oily again. And the robot actually could
handle it, but they slipped around like
ice skating. So, locomotion was okay,
but because suddenly the auto autometry
is, you know, the input is not correct.
So the navigation. So the whole thing
was just very difficult let's say and
something you cannot you know simulate
something you would really not expect um
from you know normal facilities. The
trick for us was to send engineers out
right firstand look um gather the data.
The customer was very patient with us.
Um then over time iterated on it
eventually deploy a new model update it
and now it works flawlessly but it's
been a painstaking process.
>> Yeah. From our end I mean I have tons of
worst stories. I'm going to pick u one
serious and one fun, right? So, I'm
going to start with a fun one. Um,
we've, you know, we deploy the cells and
we train them before they arrive to the
customer facility. So, the idea is for
them to get productive on day one,
right? And mostly we succeeded with
that. But in a weird case, we had this
fluctuation of performance because of
the safety system getting triggered all
the time and so on. And you know we look
at the cameras we look what's going on
around the cell nothing like we can't
see anything wrong but there is this
fluctuation of performance happening and
so we send one person to to do an eye
test of what is going on here right like
I don't know it's a power going up and
down or whatever and the person comes
there and stands in this facility and
they there's air blowing behind them and
so they turn around and there's huge
industrial fan behind our cell and they
turn around again and they see a trash
can with a flapping with a flapping bag
in the trash can that was triggering the
radars
and you know like there is no model
simulation
you know you can you can iterate on this
on the product side forever I don't
think there is an edge case with someone
says flapping trash can as part of your
product requirement or application
requirement document right and so
obviously you know now you know there is
trash can you fix that and and then
performance is good um so this was a fun
one uh on a more serious note um same
thing like you and you know numbers
right so we start working on an actual
production line again deploy goes really
well uh we get it up and running quite
quickly and you know um I'm not going to
use real numbers here but just just for
the sake of of conversation let's say
that the target was 50 parts an hour
right and we hit the target life is good
you know everybody's celebrating and so
on two weeks in the customer calls us
and like hey we need 75 parts an hour
now and obviously we we look at each
other and we're like hm all the tricks
we used for 50 like now we have to get
out of the window and kind of figure out
a 75. So we figure out a 75 right but
how do you do that without changing the
hardware without changing anything like
that's the interesting challenge that
you start facing and when you fix it
like what happens again it's like now we
need to do a 100 and so I guess the
biggest learning there is do a really
good job at collecting the data ahead of
time and then 2x whatever anybody tells
you and and you know build for that.
Yeah, surely also prepared one story. Um
yeah, like um we always try to bring in
new innovations in the field of
automation into our production plants
and we also had one example where we did
the base development. It was a AIdriven
approach where we had a reinforcement
learning approach to insert gearboxes.
We did the base development in our
innovation center and the process itself
then worked and we're like nice and now
let's go to the production side and uh
then the fun starts because you have to
think about so many other things like
the vertical IT integration like the
safety concept then you have a dynamic
environment the layout looked a little
bit different we had vibrations from a
conveyor we hadn't in mind so this was
kind of of of of a tough time we solved
it surely but this really showed that
the thing you do in your innovation
center or you do in the pre-development
phase you really have to challenge or to
match with your real environment. And I
think even today with the new simulation
capabilities we have now we did hear a
big step or do hear a big step and to
have a better engineering a better
pre-commissioning and really looking
forward to that new technologies because
I think we can close step by step this
gap even in the future.
>> Great. Thanks for all that. I'm getting
the common theme is un expect the
unexpected and there are some things
that you can plan for ahead of time as
well. getting the telemetry correct, for
example, but other things like, you
know, plastic garbage bin flaps um that
are just not possible to to predict. Um
and you know, from from the audience, I
wanted to get a feel for where
everyone's at. So, you know, who here um
has like robot fleets and deployment? Um
hands up if you you know, work in a
place that does that. Okay, you know, a
couple hands up here. And who here are
is doing it for the first time or you
know providing services or you know
models to enable that.
Okay great. Um so I think there's you
know a lot of lessons I think that can
be you know shared. Um and one of um the
questions I have is if you were doing
this um for the first time what would be
generalizable advice you could give to
the audience here? Um the telemetry is
one point. you know, is there anything
that you would um do again from the
start um to get right and shorten the
process?
>> So, so I I think there is a general
learning that comes from what Thomas
just said, right? Like is go to
production as soon as possible, right?
So, so I think until you face
production, you're just playing with a
toy um that is providing zero value,
right? and and and I think this was very
clear for us. Um you know when we when
we started with our very very first
customer um we set foot on their
facility from day one and we started to
test with their items first not on the
production line but the aim it was go to
the production line as soon as we can
afford to and and afford to means we're
not breaking anything right but [snorts]
of course as soon as we can afford to
means we're not yet ready to be you know
full-time without anyone near that that
that robot right but but the painful
full times initially on the production
line to learn all the edge cases and
make it work are invaluable because the
edge case you see there and the the
types of problems you see there have
nothing to do with what you actually
imagine in the lab or could do in a
simulation.
>> Yeah, go ahead.
>> For us certainly one of one of hard
learnings was you know do you have
everybody aligned to agree on the
problem right? if you deploy a robot and
everybody was like cool and now what
right and so it turns out you haven't
really spoken to it yet the union cyber
security safety there's so in average it
takes 5.4 for people to agree on the
problem. That's the most difficult part,
right? So, frontload as many of the
decisions and agreement as you can
before the robot even shows up because
the robot showing up, that's the easy
part. The agreement to the people,
that's that's a tough one.
>> Yeah, I'd echo that. So, I think, you
know, people think that robotics is a
problem of models, that it's a problem
of like, hey, can we get general
intelligence and so on, but I I
personally feel like it's a it's a
logistics and operations problem equally
as much. Um, and that said, you know, I
think for us really is we are good at
research, but we are even better at
productizing research. And so I think,
you know, a lot of the stuff you would
see on on Twitter or in a demo video and
so on, that is great, but if it doesn't
work with at least three nines of
reliability, like you don't even get to
the starting line in a in an industrial
environment because if you need an
intervention like every hour of the day,
that just doesn't fulfill the economic
promise, right? And so so if you go in
an industrial environment early, you
learn that where the starting line is.
You learn that, you know, there are
probably three really key areas where
you need to excel. One is robustness of
the system. So it needs to run for
thousands of hours without any any
errors. Um it needs to be autonomous for
a long time because otherwise you aren't
really fulfilling the economic promise.
If I'm selling you something that
enables you to unlock a person and move
them to a higher value station, but they
still need to tend the machine every 10
minutes, like that's probably not a not
a real uh economic value, right? Right
there. So, autonomy is really important.
And then I think the third one is is
making sure flexibility. I I think
that's another one where you know a lot
of projects and and you will probably
know uh you know it's deemed to be oh
it's a fiveyear thing. We're going to
run it for five years. It's going to be
millions of parts and so on. But the
reality is like 18 months in the market
tells you you need to change something
and then the the big investment doesn't
pay off. So you kind of have to keep
that in mind as you deploy that you are
going to have to be flexible down the
line. And again
>> yeah can agree on that um that it's not
only your technology who has to be ready
also your ecosystem in which you
integrate these technologies um but also
and you mentioned that that flexibility
is also a key driver in our production
how we design productions because we see
the markets we see the e-mobility for
example the predictability um gets less
and less and so we have to identify or
let's say design productions who are
modular who are configurable and also
then the automation solutions and we
really believe because we have so many
scenarios we have to think of what if um
that we also have to do the simulations
and surely simulation you can do on the
layout level but also on an automation
level and uh with with partners um which
are also here we we try to simulate this
contextsensitive environments to really
have an early let's say um commissioning
or let's say validation of this process
surely there's a sim to real gap and
this is then the very close the loop to
you that you have to go to the
production that you have to do your
reality capture but then use the
simulation tools we already have and
which we advancing um to do this
pre-check and pre- validation in virtual
world before you go into the real
environment.
>> Great. And when it comes to deployment
um in the sense of getting getting
prepared and getting everything aligned
before um the robots hit the floor, um
the time to value can be extremely long
in some cases. Um even putting aside
when things don't work and unexpected
things happen. Um and so when you think
about that process from installation to
the data integration to training uh the
workers there to work with the robot and
all that um before live deployment uh
would you approach this in terms of
building in-house working with partners
or is there a way to uh streamline some
of this I think bejorn mentioned
simulation as one part of it um which
approach do you use today For us it's
the sequencing right because this is a
new market customers know their problems
but they don't know how to use this
solution right so for us we do it fully
inhouse meaning that we we built the
hardware we built the AI on top of it
the capability software but also for us
the workflow integration that is key to
how we think the ROI modeling all of
that and there's you know by now we're
as proud of all this innovation in the
go to market as we are on the technology
now in the beginning that's okay you
need to be really good at it 200% %
because if you hand it over to a partner
half of it is lost in translation. We
have seen this before and so if you're
not at the 200% right they can do 100%
but if you're at 80 if you're in the
beginning it'll not work. So for us it's
clear a sequencing problem in the
beginning do it yourself direct so you
learn the quickest.
Yeah, I think 100% on this, right? Like
this this has been our conscious
strategy which is going direct to
customers so that we learn all the ropes
and we build the playbook and so that we
progressively transition to have
integrators and partners who can now
bring our solutions themselves. Um but
you know this is this is always kind of
a learning for me in channel sales that
you should always assume that a channel
cell partner is basically someone who
you know may not understand your product
may not want to sell it and um you know
have little interest in its complete
operations. And if you go with that
mindset, well, you build basically a
playbook, a product and a system and
your own control of the operations that
is fail safe from that point of view,
right? So in many cases, you may have
integrators that actually do a very good
job, right? Um they'll do an even better
job because you have all these back end.
If they don't, well, you're still safe
because you've built all those layers.
Yeah, I mean I would add that you know
you have to start in my mind from day
zero kind of building a product that
allows you then to to do these things
fast right what you described and so so
think about the entire kind of journey a
customer is going to go through like how
often are you going to see them what
data are you going to acquire where what
are the aha moments let's say for us you
know we from the very beginning like we
believe there were two real aha moments
one was when they see what we call a a
digital replica of their workstation
that it's exact same workstation they
have human tend to today tended by our
cell with no changes a couple of days
after we acquired the data that really
you know bridges the imagination gap
between oh it's like this today and it
could be like this tomorrow and you can
do the math around that and it's not
going to be precise but it is going to
be indicative of what you can expect uh
and then the second aha moment is like
okay when the machine arrives can you
get it to work within one shift right
like that that is magical. It kind of
like I I tell to my team that what we
are building should we feel closer to a
to a kitchen robot uh than you know a
system that you wait 18 months to see
move like you know you buy a kitchen
robot you plug it in and you can you can
do whatever pizza dough uh 5 minutes
later right um so that's that's super
important but then what happens after I
think is equally important so things
will go wrong as we discussed earlier so
can you you know build a system that
collects those anomaly data and and
automatically gets better time as a
fleet, right? That's an open-ended
question, but I think I think uh people
building self-driving cars uh have
showed us that it's quite possible. And
so so we are doing a lot of work on that
front where the more cells we have
running, the more data we collect around
anomalies, the next one just gets better
from all of that.
>> Yeah. And to to add up here, um how we
position MAS Sheffller, like in the end,
you have to think about the technology
readiness levels. um like we have this
let's say conventional industrial uh
robots they're in our productions they
want run 24/7 but then we also have this
new and latest technologies in the field
of humanoids so you have to have the
right partners on that journey from
let's say the low technology readiness
level up to the high technology
readiness level and surely we are
technology company we're the motion
technology company so we want to
understand and we also want to develop
technology especially in that field um
of automation um so we work with
external partners parters with a lot of
startups but also we have let's say one
unfair advantage we have one big special
machinery in house. So imagine we have
100 plants and in every plants we have
many many production lines and they are
mainly built from our internal uh
special machinery and the cool thing is
that we can develop with them also new
production line concepts and also these
kind of automation solutions and in the
end they built and integrated into this
ecosystem. So it's a a big big chance
for us also to to boost these kind of
new automation uh technologies but also
to bring in existing technologies like
um we started a few years ago with
cobalt activities. Then we moved to HVs
and now more and more humanoid robotics
applications are coming and this we do
in this close um partner network with
externals but also with our internals
and this is kind of the unique thing. Um
we have on the one hand the integrator
um position as shuffler but also we have
it as a user and I think you all heard
the presentation of Dave care. We also
provide components to humanoids. So in
the end we have the full playbook here
um and have a deep understanding in
production and then also in the systems
itself.
>> Beyond how do you decide between what
you keep owning internally versus
working with um third parties? Are there
certain parts that are more core and
more important? And I think we talked a
little about you know um uh being close
to a customer um seeing it day-to-day
and once you get a really strong sense
um of things that are repeatable then
maybe you know partnering um to scale up
but how do you decide what to keep and
what to
>> yeah um coming back to that technology
readiness level discussion like um I
would say in the earlier stages we're
very open we look for external partners
um and because like there are everywhere
new innovations and solutions um in the
market um also here I saw some nice
things already and and there we had have
a look outside and then step by step
sure we have to run our production 24/7
we have to make money in our plans um
and there we look more and more with our
SMB and also the the special machinery
um they also work with external partners
so they don't do their own copots or
robots we also buy them and integrate
them so it's a technology readiness
level discussion you have here um yeah
>> okay got it um I want to move the
conversation towards um what you see
when you talk with buyers um what are
the main considerations they have. Um,
you know, we talked a little about, you
know, sometimes, um, you know, they're
they're more focused on, uh, you know,
initially it's not speed and once it
works, you know, it's all about speed.
So, what are you seeing on the ground?
Um, what considerations do they have?
And also, um, maybe a more specific
question, uh, when you are have a couple
of robots in pilot, how do you move it
towards full-scale deployment across the
org? Is there a threshold or particular
performance metric or ROI? Um, put
another way, you know, what does like
best of look like? Um, when a client
that really loves the product is seeing,
you know, real value and robustness come
from the the platform.
>> Yeah. I I think at the end, right, like
the core of it is an ROI cell, right?
Like uh you're you're building
automation because you want to find ROI,
you want to find value. And so what
matters is to have really that
discussion early on to see what is going
to be the return on investment what what
is it going to depend on right and
customers will be um more or less open
to share all their numbers because of of
course right it's part of also of the
negotiation eventually but you need to
build a a certain level of trust so that
at least you know the core components
are clear so that you can have that
discussion about what is the throughput
at which you're going to get this RAI um
and what are the exception cases that
may happen, right? And and and how do we
handle those, right? And I think if you
define that well, um then you should get
into a situation which is what we tend
to do where we actually never sell
pilots. We always always sell in the
format of what we call oneplus x. So
basically, if I come to you, you're my
first customer, I'm going not going to
say, hey, I'm going to install a pilot
and then we'll see. I tell you, we're
going to sign a contract for let's say
20 robots. But the but if you're um
worried about the fact that you know
it's 20 robots the large investment etc.
Let's do you know one first we put all
the conditions and under which you know
if this thing works we scale to the 20
and and this fronts a little bit of the
difficult discussions because it forces
the customer to say well you know what
are the things that are like the
absolute condition under which I'm ready
to scale right and and this becomes
contractual but but that's that's really
a timesaver afterwards and and and
forces alignment within the organization
as well on the customer Right
100% we do the same thing right in the
beginning it's about was P and pilot but
what what are you trying to show right
ultimately can you define the problem
and can you solve it and so there's an
approval phase I still get that right so
two three months can you hit those KPIs
that you agreed on but from the
beginning the 5.4 four people I
mentioned right you need to have clarity
how do you fit into the company strategy
from sea level VP health and safety
right how the unions how is all those
people it wants data right everybody has
a stake in this and you need to have
clarity from the beginning the big
picture how big is this opportunity
together and then you embark on a
multi-year project with milestones we
need to do certain things and fulfill
them but also they need to do certain
things right a pilot where just a robot
runs that's clapping but who takes
decision based on the data we have
collected Right. That loop needs to be
closed and people need to see the
benefit but that work a lot of it needs
to be upfront.
>> Yeah, I I agree on that. Like maybe
maybe my view is a little bit different
because we sell to a different type of
customer, right? Like um just for the
audience maybe you know I I believe you
sell to very large companies and very
large logistics centers like we mainly
serve the high mix low volume
manufacturer. So your typical SM
European SMB industrial uh where you
know the 5.4 people is the entire
leadership team. So, so there's a few
fewer people and some of these people on
the leadership team have the same
surname as it's written on the building.
So, you kind of know who makes the
decision. But jokes aside, um you know,
our model is basically quite clear what
the ROI is because we price it as a
service on a on a particular number that
is the equivalent of roughly two
operators in the most remote part of
Europe you can find and roughly one
operator in France, UK or the western
part. So, it is the economic promise is
like there's huge labor shortage. So you
don't have people anyway and we'll help
you bridge that and you know the people
that they have they generally like and
they would want to move them to do
higher value work and so it's a it's an
easier conversation from that front but
I agree with you avoid pilots avoid
proof of concepts like we also sign like
three fouryear deals straight away and
of obviously with thresholds so we stay
in but the ROI conversation what we
realized was that if we make the number
simple like that is easy to understand
cuz obviously As you know, all these
systems are very good at counting. So,
we could meter it per part. But for our
customer base,
telling them, hey, tell me how much it
costs you to get this piece from here to
here in the process would be a
month-long homework. And you generally
don't want to do that to your customers,
right?
>> Yeah. To add up here, uh we have the the
valuedriven approach. Um we have this
discussion about shorter lab uh labor
shortage. Um but also quality is a
thing. Um and process robustness. So if
you have a solid automated process, you
somehow can uh ensure um a higher level
of quality um and also process stability
compared to to to manual workforce. And
this is also key because we we see
quality as one key measure for our
customers. Um and we also have a look on
that. And furthermore also um we when
you have this repetitive um and and and
task with high payloads, we also have a
look on the economics. So when we can
improve economics, we also have a look
on on the way that we can automate this
process. had to sum it up. Nevertheless,
and this is a thing um when you think
about scaling, we said the ecosystem
must be ready, the technology must be
ready and in the end you have to be able
to adapt very fast because we have many
changes in our layouts. We have many
changes from production lines,
customers, products and you have to
adapt in an efficient manner and I think
this is also key that you're able to
let's say adapt and let's say bring in
these automation solutions into
different cases in a very efficient way.
>> Can I add just one thing there? So yeah,
go for it.
>> I think we we missed a very important
actor kind of in this whole story which
is the operator on the on the floor. Um
you know we we talk about the leadership
making decisions, buying and so on but
at the end of the day like what we
realize is that who keeps the the cell
running and all of that is the operator
and so they also need to buy in and I I
think the design of the product and and
how much care you take about the
experience really influences that. So
it's an early bet that you should make.
Um and I think it pays back
significantly
>> and and then you're totally right with
this cultural change. So like in in our
regions we have a different technologies
which we push um and you have let's say
different states of of innovation there.
Um, and if you're in a plant where they
have their first HVs, they're like, "Oh,
what's this?" And then you're in in in
in pilot plants or in in in lighthouse
plants where you already have big fleets
and you see how the the operators
interact complete differently because it
takes some time for this kind of change
um in that environments in where they
work. Yeah.
>> Additional perspective I'd like the the
room to think about, right? In robotics
essentially we're doing work especially
humanoids, right? It's about the labor
replacement. But I think robotics can do
more. And we need to ask ourselves. You
mentioned quality, right? How can we do
a better job than a human at that task.
And so for us, the ROI is not
replicating what humans do. Yes, there's
not enough people. There's a few hours
saved, but the big ROI comes from can we
find problems earlier than a human would
because people don't see temperatures.
They don't, you know, hear the sounds
from the machines in a ultrasonic range.
All of that for sure not at the
precision of a robot. So for us the ROI
is very quickly in the 10x fold in the
millions because we stop downtime which
is in the hundreds of thousands per hour
right so always think what's the true
ROI labor replacement I think that's
that's a small one and that shouldn't be
the ultimate aspiration
>> yeah I love that challenge to see uh
what beyond h human capabilities way of
extending that to say dangerous
environments or capabilities that our
five senses like are unable to perceive
um just beyond on the pure replacing the
unit of work hours um that humans are
able to to perform. Um I know we're
quickly running towards the end of the
panel here. So uh we'll end with a quick
round robin um your your you know hot or
you know like very sensible takes on uh
what is the biggest misconception that
you think people have when it comes to
deploying robots at scale.
>> So maybe maybe I'll say thinking that
it's about one thing, right? Like I've
heard so much that you know people say
oh our company is about reinforcement
learning or my company is about that.
Well if you want to have a successful
robotics company you're going to have to
be right in a lot of things. So that's
the short take right like uh not just
one thing. You can also keep it short uh
that scaling is duplicating use cases.
It's not that simple um as we heard from
this discussion. So yeah
>> for us is you know robotics are
standardized and a lot of robotics
companies believe the world is as well
but if you go to every plant everything
is always different it is different
people are different culture is
different so there's a mismatch between
standardization robotics and reality
>> yeah I think the misconception is uh or
not a misconception but perhaps some
people that don't realize that in
robotics I think you need to go very
slow first so you can go very fast later
um because if you frontload the
solutions to some problems that will
allow you to then move much faster and
you know once you have hardware out
there I it's pretty expensive to to
replace. So that piece you know you
should do right but then you unlock kind
of all the potential of the software. So
I think the future of you know all of
the stuff we're talking about is going
to be much closer to self-driving than
to the traditional robots moving stuff
pointtooint. And I guess um you can go
see how that took 20 years to get right
or not even I mean it's not even right
yet. Okay. And last quick tick before we
break. Uh what is one capability you're
excited about which would unlock a step
change in that time to value and
deployment is a technology development
or something on their horizon.
>> From our perspective, our robots are
still, you know, assistants. The humans
tells them what to do and they can do it
reliably. However, you know, I'm excited
about practive physical agency world
models of the topics. When you truly
give contextual understanding to robot
and you unpack it and you know the whole
deployment process becomes automated
because the robots have seen thousands
of hours, thousands of different
facilities and they become an expert not
only assistant.
Yeah, generally excited about the the
steps that are about making deployment
much faster through um having
duplication of your uh physical robotic
cell that is like millimeter precision
right uh on on the on on the simulation
and being able to apply this to just
make the deployment faster.
>> Yeah, I'm I'm personally very excited
about a a sparse universe of point
technologies that are coming together,
right? Like so so similar to what you
said like you know the anything from
from the progress that is happening on
data capture 3D reconstruction world
models based on physics anchoring
leading all the way into AIdriven
robotic control. And when you put all of
that together and kind of start closing
some of these loops I I think the world
is going to look quite interesting and
and we're not that far away. I think
we're a couple of years away from from
this being the reality.
>> Can I add add to this up? I'm also super
excited for this whole chain from
reality capture to the digital
engineering and then to efficient and
fast deployment into the real world. So
really looking forward to that. Yeah.
>> Yeah. It really feels like the uh talent
the developments the scaling laws is
positioning us to crack these problems
in the next few years and um I'm excited
to see the vast you know adoption
deployment curve at that point. Um so
with that thank you very much to all our
panelists and enjoy the conference.
>> Thank you. Thank you.